قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان تلا ابيب
اقترحت صفقه للافراج عن الرهائن وان حماس
ترفض مناقشتها دون وقف اطلاق نار شامل
واضافت الهيئه ان الصفقه التي عرضتها
اسرائيل تنص على تمديد ايام الهدنه
والافراج عن معتقلين خطيرين ومن ناحيه
ثانيه افادت القناه الثالثه عشره
الاسرائيليه نقلا عن مسؤولين في الحكومه
ان الخطوط العريضه للصفقه هي اطلاق سراح
30 الى 40 رهينه مقابل اطلاق اسرا بارزين
الانسحاب بشكل جزئي من بعض المناطق مع
تهدئه لمده اسبوعين الى شهر واشار
المسؤولون انه اذا تمت الصفقه خلال
الانتقال الى المرحله التاليه فان اسرائيل
قد تغير بعض الترتيبات العسكريه داخل غزه
وانه ليس لديها مشكله في ربط حماس التغيير
العسكري بالصفقه واعتبار ذلك
انجازا معنا من الناصره محمود يزبك الخبير
ب الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ما السياق الذي اصبحت فيه
اسرائيل الان مستعده لابرام صفقه ترفض
حماس الشروط الاسرائيليه
فيها يعني في باعتقادي هنالك يعني قضيتين
اساسيتين التي ادت الى هذا التغير في
الموقف الاسرائيلي وخاصه موقف رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو نفسه اولا يعني الضغط
الامريكي الواضح وخاصه اذا تذكرنا انه كان
تصريح للرئيس الامريكي قبل اسبوع حوالي
وقال انه هذه حرب عشوائيه والقصف عشوائي
ويجب ان يتغير هذا وهذا كان تصليح هاما
ولافتا وعقبه بعده جاء العديد من
المسؤولين الامريكيين اسرائيل الى
واخرهم رئيس وزير الدفاع الامريكي مع رئيس
الاركان وبعد هذا الاجتماع تلاه كذلك يعني
ضغط عائلات الاصر الاسرائيليين بعد قضيه
قتل الاصر الثلاثه من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي وكذلك يعني في هذا السياق
عائلات الاسرى كان هنالك الشيء اللافت بعد
قتل الاسرى انه الكثير من عائلات القتلى
الاسرائيليين انضموا للمظاهرات التي
تاييدا لعائلات الاسرى وهذا يعني شيء جديد
في المشهد و وواضح جدا انه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه خاصه نتنياهو يعني اخافه هذا
الشيء لانه قد يتطور الى مظاهرات ضد الحرب
ليس فقط لقضيه الاصر بل الى ضد الحرب من
خلال من يعني ضحوا باولادهم دعنا نقول
هنالك تصريح ايضا خصوصا انه انه الجانب
الاسرائيلي كان يروج ان اهالي الجنود
القتلى يطالبون بال باستمرار الحرب لكن
على اي الاحوال نعم فيما يتعلق هنالك
تصريح نريد ان نفهم فهمه نفهم دلالاته منك
وهو تصريح المتحدث العسكري
بان الجسم العسكري جاهز لوقف
الحرب فور صدور اوامر من ذلك من الجسم
السياسي يعني حينما يقول العسكر انهم
جاهزون لوقف الحرب معناها يا اما ان الحرب
لا تحقق اهدافها او انها استنفدت اغراضها
ا فما سياق ذلك وكيف
نفهمه اولا ما تفضلت به استاذ زين بالنسبه
لانه الحرب لا تحقق اهدافها يعني بدا نقاش
حقيقي انا اعتقد جديد كذلك يعني هذا يعني
عمره ايام قليله على على صفحات الصحافه
الجديه الاسرائيليه والحديث عن هذاه
القضيه بالذات انه اسرائيل على الرغم من
تفوقها العسكري الكبير ومئات الاف من
الجنود المجندين لكن لا لم تستطع خلال 75
يوم تحقيق اي هدف عسكري او اي انتصار
عسكري لتعرضه امام المجتمع هذا واحد اثنين
في داخل ال كبريه الحرب الاسرائيلي هنالك
انقسام وهذا الانقسام واضح ويعني وظهر على
شاشات التلفزيون في الاسبوع الذي كان في
في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي شارك به الاشخاص
الثلاثه نتنياهو وجنس ويعني وزير الدفاع و
وجنس ونتيجه لهذا الانقسام
السياسي ما بين رجال سياسيين وعسكريين وفي
داخل يعني مجموعه جنس هنالك قائد رئيس
اركان سابق للجيش وهو يضغط ايزنكوت الذي
فقد ابنه خلال الحرب هذه يضغط بشكل واضح ل
الدخول في صفقه جديه وحينما يقول جديه هو
كذلك يقول بمعنى انه يجب وقف الحرب ولو
يعني لفتره طويله لكن طبعا الفتره الطويله
معناها ان تتصادم مع مطلب
حراس يفهم ايضا من هذا التصريح انه الجانب
العسكري يريد ان يتنصل من تبعات هذه الحرب
ويحملها فقط للجانب
السياسي طبعا يعني هذا هذا يعني هذه
النقطه الاساسيه التي اردت ان اصل حالا
ولذلك وجدنا نتنياهو يخرج الليله بتصريح
يعني يصعد على شجره اعلى من التي صعد
عليها وهذه عادته ان يصعد الى اشجار عاليه
ومن ثم يطلب من ينزله عنها نتنياهو هو
الوحيد بين القياديين السياسيين
والعسكريين الذي لم يتخذ مسؤوليه لم يحمل
نفسه مسئوليه الفشل في 7 اكتوبر بينما
القياده العسكريه جميعها بكل يعني
مركباتها تحملت وقالت انه نحن مسؤولين
ومستعدين ان نمثل امام لجنه التحقيق تحت
وطاه المسؤوليه نتنياهو يسعى للتخليص نفسه
وهذه بالنسبه له فرصه جديده انه يضع ال
اللوم والتبعيه على انه الجيش لم يستطع ان
يحقق الهدف الذي
وضعه المستوى السياسي وهو المستوى السياسي
ولذلك الليله حينما صرح امام الكل بانه
يعني يحلم حماس اذا اذا اعتقد انه سنوقف
الحرب يعني نتنياهو الان هو اكثر تطرفا من
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي قاد الحرب وهنا بدا
التناقض ولذلك انت ترى الليله يعني منذ
هذا اليوم المقالات التي بدات تظهر في
الصحاف
في هذه في هذا الصباح هنا في في اسرائيل
انه في نقاش جدي بدا يظهر على صفحات
الجرائد من المسؤول وهذا لم يكن هذا
النقاش لم يكن واضحا لانه كان الكل كانه م
مشغول بالمجهود الحربي ويجب ان يعطي
المجهود الحربي الاولويه الان هذا الخلاف
الذي يحدث ما بين القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه وفي داخل القياده السياسيه
نفسها بدا ينعكس في الصحافه واكيد سينعكس
كذلك على المجتمع وهذه بدايه تغير جديد
ولكن
بالنهايه يعني انا يعني نستطيع ان نفهم
انه القبول قبول شرط حماس بوقف الحرب الان
والاعلان عن ذلك معنى ذلك انه اسرائيل
الكبيره العظيمه العسكريه تقول اني انهزمت
في هذه المعركه و